for Germany Social Democrats it was the
third federal election loss in a row and
the second worst result in 60 years they
obviously got the wrong candidate with
the wrong strategy but rather than
revamping itself the party seems almost
paralyzed nobody's taking consequences
nobody is stepping down even / Steinbach
tonsillar candidate without the remotest
chance of becoming Chancellor is stayin
put vitam Cariad that applies to us as
well as to our program for the coming
years carry on the Social Democrats will
carry out my demo their one-time
prospective coalition partners the
greens are taking consequences the party
leaders are making way for new people
partly under pressure partly because
they believe in change in new blood new
ideas and new coalition's even with the
Christian Democrats if necessary the
former party of West Germany's left-wing
youth has to redefine itself young
members have to get a chance to prove
themselves I'm 100% sure that we need a
very fundamental discussion in this
party as at least as important as the
party's platform and it will keep us
busy for at least a year minocin yaba
shifting it's the third time the
red-green coalition project was rejected
by the voters partly because the SPD and
the Greens never really had a common
strategy for example on how to win back
a majority in parliament over the years
they've seen this prospect and drift
into oblivion one possible solution has
so far remained strictly taboo that is
taking the left party on board
yamam daughter born in the german
parliament we have a left-wing majority
killara at the left camp has a majority
of 8 MPs so why shouldn't we be talking
about it in spite of the Chancellor's
victory for which I congratulate her she
might be in line for a very negative
awakening I'm negativa Sara the left
party's parliamentary group leader
Gregor guzzi is thinking very hard about
coalition's his isolated party lost 3
percentage points since the last
election and 12 direct mandates even so
the left party feels like a winner the
results leave no doubt that the SPD and
the Greens have no future together
without the Left Party you think is he
veered that's hula I think they'll learn
something god I'm not saying it'll be
easy to find common ground we have our
conditions but this election showed the
SPD and greens what a huge mistake
they've made and they can't afford to
repeat it imagine how exciting it would
have been if voters had thought they had
a real alternative the Left Party is
teasing setting off an impossible
conditions during the others to make a
move it's obvious that wants to leave
its isolation and formulate new policies
with the SPD in the Greens even before a
new government has been formed yeah but
once mentioned us we'd like to see this
majority used for example for a
nationwide legal minimum wage in Germany
I hope the SPD will have the courage to
go for it but right now it doesn't look
that way donohoe's together the SPD the
greens and the left would have a
majority in parliament an unlikely
option but the Social Democrats left
wing is looking at it as a prospect for
the future
as in the guts imperative to clear this
relationship up over the next four years
the SPD and the Left Party have to act
key differences I assume this process
will get underway now understand I think
this was the last election where the
parties will say not with them every
enemy so the SPD has two conflicting
options open up to the left party or
open up to a coalition as junior partner
with the conservative and powerful
Christian Democrats a choice between a
rock and a hard place yes Pradesh did
yet snitched after Angela Merkel gutted
her last coalition partner for mark the
SPD is not getting in line or begging to
be the next one what's next a society
that's not our intention which ones were
upstaged some heated internal debates
are underway in the SPD in the Greens
especially about how to win back vote
its but even if they decide to join
forces again one thing is clear the red
green project of the gerhard schröder
error is now history
you